you said it earlier right when you
talked about what what it took for you
to become the woman it took work and
women these days aren't trying to do the
work I had a conversation earlier and I
personally as I once I realized Lauren
had daddy issues Lauren went to the
table and Lauren dealt with daddy issues
and then I began to recognize that he
issues another woman and I would talk to
them and they would self-identify daddy
issues and I was shocked I was like wait
you know you have better insurance
because if I had known earlier I fixed
some earlier I didn't know I had that
issue so until I fixed them but there
are women walking around knowing that
they are traumatized knowing that they
have gaps in them and they don't want to
address it because they don't want to do
the work it is hard work to look inside
of you and know that you can't victimize
yourself know that you have to be
accountable and to stand up and say yeah
my daddy did this he wasn't present he
wasn't whatever but that's not on him I
got to forgive him and I have to realize
what that's done for me and if I want a
healthy relationship the role the active
role that I have to play in evolving and
becoming a better person to get that